est-ce l'avion du futur ni carburant ni
pollution depuis ce matin solarim paul
survolent la suisse le test est
important ils tentent de voler 25 à 27
heures d'affilée y compris donc la nuit
nicolas chateauneuf
un vol qui défie l'imagination quand
solarim pulse d'école ce matin c'est
pour battre un record celui du plus long
vol sans autre carburant que les rayons
du soleil capturé par les immenses ailes
au moins 25 heures dans le ciel jour et
nuit à bord du cockpit le pilote savoure
l'instant
c'est vraiment un moment spécial très
important toute l'équipe attend ça
depuis le début depuis presque sept ans
et on le comprend car l'avion est un
condensé d'innovation sa structure en
fibre de carbone lui permet d'avoir des
ailes aussi large qu'un airbus a340 tout
en limitant le poids à celui d'une
voiture sur les ailes douze mille
cellules solaires fournissent
l'électricité aux batteries et aux
quatre moteurs tout a été testée et
prouvée conçu pour alléger l'ensemble
même le cockpit du pilote a été soumis
au plus rude épreuve
actuellement l'avion vole à huit mille
deux cents mètres d'altitude au dessus
de la suisse les conditions météo sont
excellentes les batteries chargées avant
d'affronter la nuit sauf de croiser les
doigts on avance dans l'inconnu t'as
rien n'est certain nathan hines
certaines thèses jusqu'au bout on ne
sait pas ce qui peut arriver
si tout se passe bien sûr la rime punch
devrait tenter le tour du monde en 2013
une nouvelle alerte à la